You are listening to radiolab radiolab
from W N y.
S. E. N. P. Are you ready Robert? Hey,
I'm Jad Abumrad and I'm Robert
Krulwich. This is radiolab, the podcast,
the podcast today on radio
lab. We are the, well,
I'd actually don't even
know what we're doing.
I know we're revisiting some old
questions, but you've kept me in the dark.
So what are we doing today on the podcast?
Well today we're going to
chicken with who? Who's here?
Somebody who you might remember actually.
Oh, Hi Robert. How are you doing?
Can you just tell me who you are?
Just say I'm Josh and where you
are and what you do and style.
I am Joshua Green.
I am an assistant professor of
psychology at Harvard University. And,
and you may remember second
grow and in the morality show.
Sure. I mean Josh was the
guy with the moral puzzles.
I study moral judgment
and decision making.
Are you going to get into the hole baby?
Would you kill your baby question? Yes,
exactly. Exactly.
So for those of you who need to follow
this in that earlier radio that we
described, the last episode
of the TV show Mash,
it's wartime isn't any
patrol coming down the road.
You are hiding in the basement
with some of your fellow villagers.
Let's kill those lights. And
the enemy soldiers are outside.
They have orders to kill
anyone that they find quiet.
Nobody make a sound until the
[inaudible]. So there you are here
huddled in the basement,
all around your enemy troops and
you're holding your baby in your arms,
your baby with a cold, a bit of a sniffle,
and you know that your baby could
cost at any moment. [inaudible]
they hear your baby, they're gonna find
you and the baby and everyone else,
and they're going to kill everybody.
And the only way you can stop this from
happening is cover the baby's mouth.
But if you do that, the baby's
going to smother and die.
If you don't cover the baby's mouth,
soldiers are going to find everybody
and everybody's going to be killed,
including you, including your
baby, and you have the choice.
Would you smother your own baby to save
the village or would you like your baby
cough? Knowing the consequences
and, and, and, and,
and, and it may clear for me why, where
we're going with this, Robert, like,
I don't know.
You asked me a question at the time
and how many people chose to kill their
baby? About half. Wow. That's not bad.
What do you mean slept? You're in
favor of killing the baby. Well,
what would you do? Me,
I would never, I would,
I wouldn't even consider
kill the baby. You would,
the village will go on to have a
hundred babies. Your babies. Just one.
My baby is my world,
my babies, my universe.
So you're going to erase all those
people based on your one child.
First of all,
the audience should know that [inaudible]
not does not have a child of his own.
Yes. Okay. Now,
now we have the benefit of time passing.
Yeah. Just out of sheer curiosity,
now that you have a child
and you've looked into that
child's face over and over
and over again, I'm
just curious, would you,
is there any other reason why you're
doing no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no.
I'm going to know you and that
young people shouldn't worry,
but just out of curiosity,
what would you do?
But I killed the baby when I your
baby, not a baby. You are baby
[inaudible].
Would you like to see a little picture
of him? No, I don't want to see a photo.
I know what a meal looks like
for crying out loud. So just,
no, see, here's, I,
I have thought about this actually because
people send us emails about this for
some reason. Um, um, I don't really know.
I mean the thing is though, I mean now
there's not just like an abstract baby,
but it's my baby. Well that does
change everything obviously.
So I'm kind of in a place where I don't
really know that frankly, don't know.
Wait, let me just think about this.
I Dunno.
It's kind of an impossible question cause
like in order to answer it truthfully,
which is I would not kill my baby,
I'd have to sacrifice a principle,
which is like not as important
to me as my baby. But almost
that principle being,
well it's sometimes you have to sacrifice
something very dear for the greater
good. I just think that's a really, I
mean, not to get all communistic on you,
but that's a really important idea to me.
And in this case, by the way, the, the
calculus of what is about to happen,
if the baby cost is
really not known to you.
Well, I mean, if you, you know,
if you're the philosopher king
and you give me two options,
one is to kill my baby, to save the
village or to allow my baby to live,
in which case everybody dies. If
those were the only two options,
then I still feel like you
kind of have to kill the baby.
[inaudible] [inaudible]
but I don't think I could do that. I
don't think any father could do that.
So th my sort of pathetic answer at
this point is I can't kill my baby,
but then I can't sacrifice the
village. So I think I would just, um,
like close my eyes and
wish I was [inaudible]
where else?
So the idea is that, you know,
when you think about this case,
on the one hand you have an intuitive
emotional response that says, no,
this is terrible killing a baby or
killing my own baby. Even worse,
at the same time, a different system
within your brain is saying, look,
this is horrible as this is,
this is a sensible thing to do.
It's the only sensible thing to do because
if you do nothing, everyone will die.
Whereas if you kill the baby, then at
least you and the other people can live.
And uh,
w what the evidence suggests is that
these two competing moral perspectives are
really grounded in different
parts of the brain. The,
and the competition is not been resolved.
That's where we were the last time. Right?
Now I want to step forward for a second
and think about it a little more deeply.
All right.
If our sense of right and wrong comes
from like these competing brain systems.
Let me revisit the question.
Are Our brains built
to fever? Certain outcomes.
Let's suppose that you are
walking alongside a lake
and you see a girl drowning
right in front of you and
she's screaming for help,
but you're wearing a very expensive suit.
Should you jump into the
lake and saver? No, no,
of course. Of course you should. Yes.
You mean like the suit is the only thing
that's preventing me from doing that?
Yeah,
but now suppose you're walking down past
your mailbox and there's a letter in
the mailbox,
which is please give us $1,000 so we
can help save girls on the other side of
the globe. Girls, you'll never meet
girls who screams. You'll never here,
but there are girls in trouble on the
other side of the world. Go help them.
And so wait until the, the equivalence
is that you jump into the lake.
You say if the girl who's
drowning one-on-one or you
send the check and you save
the girl who is in peril,
a girl, not that girl,
a girl somewhere on the
other side of the globe.
So the question that go to Josh, if
you didn't give the thousand dollars,
would that make you a bad guy? Well,
there is something funny about
these cases, right? That,
that most of us say that of course
you have to rescue the drowning child,
but you know, it's, you're not a saint
if you don't give your money over to, to,
to save the children on the
other side of the world,
but you're certainly not a terrible
person or so it seems to us. And so, yes,
there's this, there's this, uh, putting
aside whether it's a good or bad,
whether you're a good or bad person,
how do you explain the difference? Well,
I think it makes a lot of evolutionary
sense. Uh, that is, you know,
a lot of our social emotional responses
are geared towards life in the kind of
environment in which
our ancestors evolved.
And it makes sense that we would
have a moral buttons so to speak.
They get pushed by the kinds of things
that our ancestors might've encountered
cause tens of thousands of
years of evolution have have
essentially been quietly
tugging at your heart in both in those
kinds of seats actually. Exactly.
Where is the idea?
The idea of spending a minimal amount of
money to save the life of some stranger
on the other side of the
world that you've never,
that you're never going to meet. Um,
that's a totally new modern phenomenon.
It's not something that our
emotions are our prepared for.
Well now doesn't that leave us in a
funny place because I think it does.
What happens if the most
important questions that we
face as a species or as a
group involve thinking
abstractly those problems,
pollution, global warming
and things like that.
Those aren't really local
problems. They're global problems.
Exactly. This is,
I think that gets right at the heart
of the matter and this is why I do this
research. I think that the kind of
thinking that we apply to those problems,
what we call common sense is really hunter
gatherer or common sense or at least
a lot of it is. And uh,
if we're going to face these big problems
that were our minds were not designed
by evolution to handle,
then we have to learn to turn off parts
of our brain that are getting in the way
and turn on other parts that may seem
like the wrong parts to be using.
So he's saying that we
should tamp down primitive
emotional instincts that are in our
reptile brain. Let those instincts say,
don't kill your baby like that
stuff. And then we should,
we should amp up somehow the, uh,
the part of us that thinks more abstractly
about the greater good and about
people that aren't right in front of it.
Yeah. So, so if you're sitting there with
a soda can in your hand and you think,
oh, I guess I can just throw this on
the street and you'll get clank, clank,
clank of the clinic, your
primitive parsing. Well,
I can get away with that
cause no one's seeing it.
But of course the
calculating part would say,
well if we all do this then the
world will be full of trash.
And it's problems like that
that in order to solve that,
you have to think abstractly
why that's interesting.
Because we might be, I mean,
I think he might be wrong. I mean,
cause we didn't countered this already.
He's asking us to rely on a part
of our brain that, you know,
is not exactly Hercules'. Do you remember
the thing we talked about in the,
in the show is that Soren, was
it the, the choice show, uh,
with the Bobby Shiv. Can we get that
audio and throw that into the mix?
I'm a Baba share. I'm a
professor here at, uh,
the Stanford Graduate School
of Business in marketing.
A lot of my research it has to do with
the brain and tricking people. Oh yeah,
absolutely. So Robert,
I want to tell you about one
particular experiment that he did.
So the experiment is pretty
straight forward. There's like this,
you got a bunch of subjects
together. He said, okay,
I'm going to give you all a number,
the number on a little card.
You're going to read the number and I
want you to commit that number to memory.
Take as much time as you want to
memorize the number, and then he says,
you'll know going to walk to the next
room and recalled the number and that's
what subjects think test subjects think
that they're going to be doing so they
know they're going to be in one place.
Getting a number of going into another
place and reciting that number.
That's right. That's all they
know. That's all they know,
but they don't know is that not everybody
is getting the same kind of number.
Some people get a seven digit numbers.
Some people get a two digit
number that I can do. By the way,
I think I can do two digit.
No, I doubt it.
All the subjects have to do is they've
got to memorize a number of walk out of
room one down the hall of room
to then recite their number.
Now just imagine you and me person with
a two digit number in their head and was
walking out of room one. Two is my number.
I can definitely remember
this down the hall,
the same time someone with seven
digits in their head and two eight,
nine walks down the hall.
Now here's where the trickery comes
in as they're walking down the hall,
mid memorizing. All of
a sudden, excuse me,
they pass a lady in the hallway and
she's holding something up to you,
but would you like a
snack? Um, she says here,
have it have a snack. Just as our,
as our way of saying thanks for
participating in this study.
You can have one of two snacks.
You choose between a big fat slice of
chocolate cake or be a nice bowl of fruit
salad. Meanwhile, they've both got
these numbers still in their head.
Now here's the weird thing. When
they finally make their choice,
what would you like? Some yummy cake
or some healthy fruits and the people,
this is crazy. The people with two digits
in their head. You know, I love cake,
but I think I'll take the
fruit. Almost always choose
the fruit healthy.
Whereas the people with seven digits
in their head almost always choose the
cake. You know the cake. I want the cake
and we're talking by huge margins here.
It was significant. I mean, this
was like in some cases a 20,
25 30 point difference. The,
the lesson we took from that,
which is the lesson you
are not telling me now,
is that your rational system,
the hope of humankind,
part of your brain is very,
very suggestible week and almost barely
struggling to manage the situation.
Give us something too much to do. And
Oh man, it just, it each week cake.
I would take a very different
lesson from that study.
Imagine if you told those people who
say, look, here's how your mind works.
When you have to remember,
remember a long number,
it's going to clog up your memory and
it's gonna make it harder for you to
resist the temptation to have chocolate
cake instead of fruit salad. Um,
but I'm telling you this now,
you're armed with the truth about how
your own mind works. Here's a long number.
Go right now.
How many of those people are going to
be able to resist the chocolate cake?
I think a lot more of them are
right. Has anyone done
that? Has anyone said, okay,
I'm sending you down and that is
going to be this siren seductive.
Take handling a temptress and
let's see if you can resist it.
Has that ever been done?
It hasn't. I don't know if it's been done,
but I'm willing to place bets
on how that will turn out.
That is that we can recognize the quirks
and the flaws and the inconsistencies
in our cognitive systems and do
something better. That makes more sense.
[inaudible]
does that, does that a,
is this just blind optimism hiring or
does he have evidence to support this?
Well, one thing that gives me hope
is something called the Flynn effect,
the Flynn effect.
So the Flynn effect is something that
was noticed by a philosopher now,
political scientist named uh, Jim Flynn.
I knew it was going to be Flynn. Yeah.
Who is really surprising if his
name was [inaudible]. That's right.
Know that they, they, they,
they line these things up so that
they make sense of the Flynn effect,
the Flynn effect.
What Flint noticed is that over
the course of the 20th century,
IQ scores kept going up and up and
up in the industrialized world.
So much so that by his estimates,
a person of average intelligence in 1900
would register somewhere near the line,
uh, for mental retardation,
by present standards. Um,
how could this be same test by
the way. So everything, I mean,
that's why it's a bit complicated because
the tests have changed and the norms
have changed, but doing your best to
control for all of that. By his estimates,
we have gained about 30 IQ points as
a society in the last hundred years,
which is enormous. Now, there are a
lot of people who would say, well,
the IQ test really doesn't really tell
you that we're getting smarter or really
different Bot.
If you ask Josh, well, why would we
be getting better at the IQ test?
He says that in the last hundred years
people learn how to think abstractly,
crude oil,
palm dirty things that
we take for granted.
Like thinking about abstract things
like a market where a market is not a
particular place with fruit stands,
but a more abstract space so to speak,
in which goods and services
are exchanged for money.
He's to fit these [inaudible] toe
to bed, five to 10 Havi. I'll bet
things like that have become part of
the our cognitive Boucher meaning,
and I think this is how Josh would
argue with these are deeply abstract
occupations mean natural gas to try to
figure out patterning and numbers and
future values,
crude oil, natural gas, edit it.
I think Josh [inaudible]
it can change you.
Cultural Evolution essentially has given
us much higher iqs when it comes to
thinking about a lot of things. Wow.
So you're saying that we are learning
to exercise our rational systems.
It's not that we're growing
any new brain cells,
we're making a whole new
set of connections. It's
just that what we've got,
we're just making more muscular. Exactly.
It's like learning to play
an instrument. Right? I mean,
when you first start playing
guitar, you're totally useless.
It sounds like a dying animal,
uh, end, but you know, give it a,
give it a couple of years and it can
sound great. And basically we're,
that's a very specific
sort of motor skill, right?
But being better at abstraction
and thinking about right
and wrong in a new way.
That seems, that seems what you're
saying is kind of down. Well, I mean,
you think that you can exercise yourself
into being a better man and a better
woman and a better speaker.
I think that's right.
I think that we can learn to play our
dorsolateral prefrontal cortices better.
At the end of the day.
You think that the pressure of dealing
with these big abstract problems will
eventually change our minds?
Well, I hope so. I mean,
the problem is that as a species we
tend to learn from trial and error. Um,
the problem with issues like
nuclear proliferation and
global warming is that we
only have one earth and it are,
what I hope is that if we have to learn
the lesson from some kind of trial and
error, the errors are not so big
that we don't get another chance.
But I also think that there's reason for
optimism, or at least you hope think.
Yeah. At least I hope
you know. But I mean,
I may just be because I'm an
optimistic person. I mean,
I might just sort of throw up
my hands and say, forget it.
I'll go do something else, enjoy my
time before we kill ourselves. But, um,
I think that, you know,
I the, it makes sense.
It's worth a shot to see if we can teach
ourselves to live happily on a, on a,
on a small planet.
[inaudible]
I heard you. The teacher. Wow. Yeah.
I'm pretty pretty. Pretty. Dantic Huh?
Teach in the world.
No, no. I kind of mean,
I certainly think anyone normal but be
rooting for you. Absolutely. Thanks.
I appreciate that. There are a lot
of abnormal people who root for me,
but I hope [inaudible] Josh Green is
an assistant professor of psychology at
Harvard University written these ideas
in an essay in a volume called what's
next edited by Max Brockman and hey,
did you, when you were talking with him,
did you ask him about his babies? What
would he kill his babies? You know,
I should, I forgot any case. We
should. We should wrap it. Yeah.
He killed this baby cause the, the,
we have to see our funding, right?
So Radiolab is supported in part by the
National Science Foundation Corporation
for public broadcasting and one
other, the Sloan Foundation,
which by the way is supporting Kepler
to Phillip Glass Opera about the great
17th century astronomer.
It's premiering November 18th right
down the street from me as the Brooklyn
Academy of Music. I'm Jad Apple Rod.
I remember going into listening.